I do not believe that there are people
who do not piss in the shower uh that's
that's a genuine belief because I I
could not imagine you know I'd
understand if it was like a communal
shower or whatever like that you know if
you're sharing like a public shower okay
yeah you know I didn't do that in my
University dorms or whatever but in your
own house come on why yeah I piss him on
Joe yeah yeah we all agree with that
yeah yeah yeah well you were like no a
second ago well I try not to oh yeah I
try and like pee before I go on the show
yeah but you're about to like flush a
bunch of water away with the shower
anyways if it's yellow let it mellow
unless
it's like yellow I I just let that [__]
mellow out oh my God asparagus day yeah
oh asparagus day yeah I'm flushing that
[__] but
sometimes yeah I mean if if it's yellows
you just you gotta flush that [__] man
that's that [__] stinks yeah but
sometimes you if you've been drinking a
lot of water your piss is like basically
clear I just drink it
I'm like why I let this get away
right on top
no like if you've been drinking a lot of
water or just you know drinking a lot of
fluids then your pee is like very clear
and in that case you're not going to see
the difference and it's not going to
smell so I'm just like sometimes I just
can't hit the first morning pee Oh first
morning piece like getting a yellow
that's always just so like
sometimes like the the force that it
goes in it just bubbles up oh my god oh
it's gross sorry do you like the feeling
first thing in the morning you know
sometimes it's like a cold day or
something like that uh I don't know why
I like this feeling uh because I only
get it when I wake up first thing in the
morning but you have a good quality
Shake
what do you get that in the winter what
when when it's like a really really cold
day and you're holding in a piss and
while you're peeing your body just kind
of like that I have had that I have had
that I didn't know I didn't know that I
know exactly what [__]
I didn't know this was the thing I
thought it was just a mean thing it's
because I I remember I looked into it
because I was like why the [__] what is
wrong with me and so I looked into it
apparently that's your body's weight
because you're releasing a lot of heat
from inside your body because your pee
is yeah body temperature right so the
body releasing all of that heat all at
once your body just goes into like a
little like a shiver because now your
core body temperature is a little bit
cooler have you have you ever tried
pissing in the dark
what do you mean of course I have yeah
yeah how good is you how good is she
gonna make it my aims how good is yours
oh as in like in the middle of the night
yeah okay it's the middle of the night
okay you're with a group of people yeah
and uh you don't want to turn the lights
on
um and also you don't want to piss on
like the water as well because you know
that'll wake people up I just sit down
you just sit down [__] I should do that
I just sit down now I'm like I've had
too many instances where I thought the
ball was here it was actually over here
and I'm like oh that sounds like it's
not going in the bowl at all and I
turned the line on like
it is it has happened a few times when
I've had the piss of Faith where you
position
you position them where you think that's
all it is you don't want to wake people
up yeah it's the middle of the night and
uh yeah it's it's it's it's the piss of
faith and you find out whether you do
not want to turn the light on because I
don't want to Blind myself yeah
sometimes you know you don't want to
blind yourself and sometimes you just
don't want to wake people up as well
okay yeah I don't know I'm gonna wake
them up for me if I I pick with the door
open I guess yeah yeah actually I I mean
if if I piss at night I never turn the
lights on just because when I turn the
lights on even if it's just like why are
you on nightmare difficulty for pissing
dude I don't know like my because my
brain my brain weird as soon as I see
like lights it's like my brain my brains
like signal to be like whoa you wake up
now why is this the only time you're
going dark mode
brightness now
now the nights to be fair because my
brain is wide in a way to to be like if
I see lights mode or if I see let me
wake up I'm going to wake up and I've
had it a few times where like the worst
thing is is like I I because I know
because I know how my body works and
sometimes the worst thing is when I have
like a midnight [__] and when I just
wake up someday and I'm like I need to
[__] I sleep better after I have the
poop
yeah yeah but like if I pee when I I
really needed to pee it helps me get to
sleep so so my parents actually at last
time I went back to my parents place
they figured out the perfect oh my God
your [__] toilet they had [__] LED
lights underneath no way I literally I
remember I I went home last time and
it's been like first time I went home
since covert right so I'm like I'm
looking around the house looking for
small chains of being like Oh that's
moved or like they added this or
whatever I walk into the toilet and just
immediately game a toilet it's just like
blue LED it doesn't like uh like
Republic of gamer yeah it does it is but
I was like this is so genius because now
I don't have to sit down because I can
see exactly where it is and it's not
blinding I love sentencing so I prove
way prefer it I don't mind it what do
you mean it's my preferred go to but
sometimes it's just gonna be fall into
like pull my pants all the way down you
know you pull them all the way down you
know from the [__] ankles every time
right from a little bit there I can't
sit press bro what I don't know my my
you know you know me with my like shit's
right as soon as because sit down equals
poo poo time
what is going on with your simple chimp
brain we're sitting down makes you want
to poop okay you know me I I hate the
feeling of like not being like empty if
if I sit down and poop I'm if if I if I
don't empty myself you can empty
yourself and sit down with peeing yeah
but like if I sit down sometimes it's
like oh this is all like this is a half
this this has gone from uh like a quick
one minute pee to like a half hour
you've nerfed yourself oh you've snuffed
your entire body for something I just
[__] reason sometimes my body I like
I overcome this feeling can't get past
it I've learned to live with my body I I
know my body's limits I don't know the
name of your [__] autobiography
with my body yeah yeah if I sit down
there at times when I'm like oh [__] I
need to go and then as as soon as like
that as soon as that has hit my brain
I'm like oh I'm stuck here now I can't
stand up until until yeah you have the
fan you feel like as an adult you're
just be will like you're beholden to the
weird
perks you've picked up from yeah being a
kid and that you're like well I can't
change anything now
I I there's there are some perks that I
have picked up like I used to be able to
sleep no matter what the situation was
anywhere
um and now sleep just sleep is just it's
not harder but there are like certain
I've noticed there are certain preset
conditions for me to get a good night's
sleep and I've never like I've never had
that before in my life I need I need
okay what is the for me I need the room
to be pitch [__] oh yeah I can't have
any amount of light I'm like if if the
curtain is like slightly open I'm using
that [__] all the way yeah I know it
makes no difference but I found that
no I can't do it I love waking up and my
room is [__] bright as [__] oh yeah I
don't mind that in the morning but the
problem is is that like the light coming
from outside during the night keeps me
up
oh no it doesn't do that yeah so I need
to be like completely like basically the
equivalent to just shutting your eyes in
a dark room in order for me to sleep a
lot of light in my window so I guess
it's fine yeah I have like a big [__]
window in my bedroom so it's like I need
that curtain all the way closed yeah
part of the reason that I felt so tired
every day on tour uh was just the fact
that I was not waking up to natural
sunlight yeah because of that reason
like my body was just like continually
tired as after I worked yeah I hated it
I I need sunlight to wake up I thought
we had this conversation as well yeah
yeah yeah exactly I think that's just
like everyone though right I I feel like
I know really no Chris absolutely does
not want the curtains open or blinds
open at any point it's like whenever we
share rooms I'm like oh my God we have
to [__] like bunker the whole [__]
room down to make sure one crumb of
light doesn't get in the room wake up at
Furious in the middle of the night yeah
I think that's why I'm you know kind of
gel with Chris whenever we're sleeping
in the same hotel room problem is still
can't get to sleep because he snores
like a [__] goddamn land
yeah um I need like a half hour to an
hour cool down period before I actually
like like some people can just like go
to sleep like that I need like I need
like a cooldown period when I just lay
on the bed and just chill out like Get
Low to sleep uh yeah I'm the equivalent
of like when you turn your computer off
and then it starts updating yeah yeah
I'm pretty tired by the time I get to
bed so as long as I get in a position
that my I think my brain has tricked
myself like this is a sleeping position
yeah I think I fall asleep pretty
quickly yeah like like as like I was
saying earlier you know when I wake up
to go for like a midnight piss or like a
midnight [__] when I just wake up uh
because I didn't go to the toilet
beforehand
um I have like a I have like a timer and
I know like it's it's weird because I
kind of get what you mean I consciously
know that there's a timer so when I take
a [__] um if I don't [__] fast enough
there's a timer for my brain to be like
okay you you are asleep enough to go
back to sleep too oh you're awake yeah
yeah you're awake now and you're not
getting back to sleep and uh you you
took too long to [__] the timer's run
now your [__] timer his run out your
[__] timer has run out brain awake you
do not go back to sleep and I'm like I
hate that because I can physically I can
physically feel my brain waking up I'm
like no no come on that's like one
that's like one thing I'm glad I got my
body got rid of is that like I used to
take midnight shifts every night well
you can you can kind of when I was in
high school but now I don't do it I'm
pretty sure you can somehow control your
bowel movements I don't know how
that is like teach me master I need to
know all that [__] yeah I'm pretty sure
because like
I I poop at the exact same time near
enough every single day same and yeah I
don't know if that's good or bad but I
feel like I I know how to change it if I
want but I don't know how for me it's
not so much like the same time of day no
[__] sense yeah for me it's not so
much the same time of day for me it's
the same point of while I'm awake uh
yeah pretty much it's like for me it's
like no matter what time I wake up an
hour after I'm up I'm [__] yeah yeah
that's why I mean like 6 a.m it could be
[__] 1pm it's like always I I need my
morning [__] as much as I need my
morning shower that's like that's how
ingrained it is into my cycle that's why
I'm the only one that actually had to
stop the bus on tour to go [__] just
just because it'll like on that
particular day I could hold it I can
hold it I can't hold it man I woke up
early I woke up like I I say woke up
early I think we were just on on a very
long drive and it was like 9am and I
woke up and I'm like oh no I've woken up
and the bus is still moving and then I I
remember I remember
I remember thinking because I think we
were driving through Utah and it was
like such a beautiful landscape and I I
woke up I go into like the living room
and like our tour family is just like oh
my God look at like look all over Utah
mountains and Mike's next to me like yo
bro this is so [__] beautiful and I'm
like yeah it's uh beautiful and inside I
was like I feel it coming the shit's
coming just distract yourself just
distract yourself look at look up the
landscape and I remember everyone kept
commenting on the landscape and all I
could think about was how much I needed
to [__] in this very moment and how
close we were so yeah yeah that's a
great place to take a [__]
oh
it was like we're pretty isolated right
now I could uh I could maybe I could
like get away with this you know maybe I
could move in the wilderness huh or
[__] yourself no going up to Lego
[__] like what you're gonna shoot
yourself on the bus
get away with it
I could go over like one of these mounds
and no one wanted to see anything
positions you sleep stomach backside I
cannot sleep anything but on my back
yeah oh well for me it's either back or
right side
yeah but so I I thought I was a side
sleeper but I realized I'm more of a
like
third side two-thirds stomach I'm kind
of like this oh yeah kind of like side
but with my stomach leaning towards the
bed I cannot sleep on my back I do not
know why I'm unable to sleep on my back
I've tried many times and I cannot fall
asleep you're like I don't know I feel
like as and I want to learn
I'm like do you still sleep that we're
in futons as well uh yeah yeah okay okay
always on my sides and I didn't kind of
use my arms as like a like support
because I feel like the reason I sleep
on my back was just because as a kid uh
you know every time you go to Asia
sometimes you don't have a bed to sleep
on you sleep on kind of like a futon or
some covers on the floor and it's just
impossible to do that unless you're
sleeping on your back I feel like I kind
of like that I like my arms crumbled up
feeling though I'm squishing them
against the floor right it feels nice
have you I have this thing where I like
develop what I call T-Rex arms when I
sleep where I'm just [__] like this
no I do that too yeah yeah yeah I've
seen that actually my favorite my
favorite Strat is the arm under the
pillow yeah but no one my head is just
like pillow here right in front right
yeah I love that feeling if they're just
a slight elevation I don't know why it's
so good I have that I feel like I'm in a
Sci-Fi movie when I sleep because I need
to be perfectly like straight like that
like I'm going to cry asleep I'm like
terrified if I [__] rob God's house
and I just see a man
[Laughter]
just goes like
what was that [__] T100 yeah because
like sometimes if I sleep on my I've
tried sleep on my side and I just wake
up because sometimes I just get cramps I
don't know yeah oh man old man yeah if I
sleep on like in like a weird position
where it's like not on a normal side
maybe I'm so tired that I don't [__]
care what position I sleep in next
morning I am stiff like my shoulders are
[__] aching and I'm like yeah [__]
all right what time I woke up as a kid
and my my head was like so I can imagine
I don't know how to explain it like head
in the on the bed and then my like knees
I was like on my knees though so I was
like oh kind of like you're like
snailing kind of like a snail yeah
imagine a snail like that
like knees on the [__] bed and my
legs were kind of like up I guess yeah I
was like what the [__] do you have this
problem I because I constantly have this
problem with futons I wake up and the
pillow is nowhere near my head no I
don't have that do you have this no you
fighting the [__] pillow I don't
[__] know like I'm like I clearly
yeah I'm like when I sleep in a futon I
always have to sleep in my back yeah
because you know there's less panning
right between you and the floor so I'm
always sleeping on my back head is
perfectly on the pillow like supporting
my neck and I'm like all right good I
just have to stay in this position yeah
and I'm good till the morning wake up
the next morning I'm somehow on my
[__] side like on the corner of the
futon and I'm like where did the pillow
go and it's like all the way up it's
just on the ceiling yeah yeah it's just
like if the futon is here the pillow is
like down here and I'm like how
no matter what state of mind you're in
do you always feel like you need like a
kind of like blanket or something
covering yeah yeah because uh yeah
that's something that's like remained
true no matter what even like even
during our degenerate days when we went
to like House parties and University of
course sometimes you get inebriated in
some stranger's house and I would always
need something yeah even if it's on the
floor I could sleep fine I'll find a
[__] pizza box which cover which has
no installation whatsoever but I've
woken up with a pizza box I've put over
myself do you remember one time when we
went
this is years ago uh but remember one
time when we also used to live near each
other yeah we went to like a house party
I think it was maylene's place and I was
so [__] like just shit-faced yeah
that you dragged me back to your house
and I woke up the next morning with two
pieces of cardboard
and I'm just like lying on Connor's
couch like this with two pieces of
[__] like Amazon boxes I I didn't
have any because I literally just moved
in yeah yeah all I had was a couch and a
bunch of cardboard boxes so I could part
a bunch of cardboard boxes on top of
them to like help him I guess like
January yeah I remember this I had no
Heating and I was like I wake up the
next morning freezing with these like
two [__] boxes with me I'm like what
no because I I forgot about that I
remember the night because I remember
taking him home with you because I
thought I was like sober I clearly
wasn't sober because I remember I was we
got Sydney up to the couch and oh I
remember asking Connor Connor do you
have do you have any spare blankets and
he just goes no and then we look around
and there are all of the cardboard boxes
that Connor has just finished unpacking
and we were just like we can fashion a
blanket out of this this is fine this is
fine why did you stay in my house and
why did I not take you to yours I don't
know why I don't know they're all drunk
I think I think because because we took
a taxi and it was a small place yeah
there's a little bit of a walk from
yours to mine and I think you in your
drunken state made the right decision of
I don't think he can make it yeah yeah
yeah
yeah because I I remember thinking yeah
I don't know Joey's like actual address
yeah and my uh Japanese wasn't good
enough like direct the taxi driver yeah
so we're like let's just let's just stay
I can't just I remember walking out of
that house being like Joey's so drunk
and then uh I'm a flight I was like a 10
minute walk from Connor cells like I
remember walking like the like Direction
I thought was going to home I walked for
what I thought was five minutes I'm like
I remember just looking up and being
like
what the [__] am I I look at the I look
at the clock I've been walking for 30
minutes and Sydney's like I've Cindy's
like where the [__] are you I literally
had no idea where I was and somehow in
my drunken stupor I'd walk in half an
hour of the wrong direction from my
house if I'd realize I was lost so yeah
that was that was that was a good night
yeah I got my stepson got my got my
goddamn steps then